so what let's talk about Levin's blind
though so so how does this show work
well like you said it's like the dating
version of the voice so that's all
people can go off of is they we have 15
single guys and 15 single girls in these
dating pods and they talk to each other
for days weeks with no cell phone no
television no computers no family and
friends in their ear and they just get
to that's just sounds like vacation all
they have is communication like the old
school way of getting to know somebody
and like talking and asking questions
about them it's not about the
superficial stuff what you look like or
what do you it's just really about who
are you like not a filter not the
picture you chose to be your profile did
he describe you himself to you cuz we
knew what both sexes looked like and
she's like yeah he said he looked like
so-and-so and I was like no but honestly
people felt so in love so quick that
when they did see each other they were
like it's even better than I thought and
there were a couple that they're like
okay we got okay okay we'll just try
this and then they cog and they're like
okay okay we pretty much every scenario
you can peek you'd imagine playing
itself out and they do have played
itself out this is where you're worried
that like people wouldn't cuz don't
people end up getting engaged right
that's the whole thing you have to
propose to someone sight unseen and
accept their proposal without ever
having seen them and only after you
accept do you finally see the person
you've been talking to you for hours and
hours and hours but but we didn't ask
anybody nobody was forced to propose so
we actually after week one we're like if
nobody proposes then we have to figure
out what the show is cuz then the social
experiment would be nobody found love
without seeing each other physically
well we got plenty of proposals and
again everything you could imagine going
down did going down even that's a whole
lot got rid of like any be uncomfortable
kind of vibe like somebody media people
it's always like oh my god like can you
just you get to be yourself behind that
blip did you get away from other people
in your ear like what are you seeing her
why are you talking about we're going
right that's the word that's annoying
when people I'm like did I ask you yeah
it's all about the connections between
you and the person on the other side of
that wall and and the connections they
formed were like it just crazy strong it
in like two days like yeah grown men are
weeping what here's just this show is
gonna be exactly subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going